you wanna play games do you Batman save
the city or catch your greatest enemy do
you think you're my greatest enemy well
Drive you to one-up them the way that I
do
Superman Superman's not a bad guy I like
to fight around you seriously saying
that there is nothing special about us
there is no us
never will be now they're gonna defuse
that bomb
[Music]
hey computer I'm home I'm home master
Bruce you need to take responsibility
for your life and it starts by raising
the young orphan you adopted
it's the Batcave I get a costume fine I
love it I got negiah room it's better I
can only look you in the eyes right now
Gotham City is the most crime-ridden
city in the world we need to team up
with Batman what I'm back introducing
the worst villains in the history of the
universe the Riddler Catwoman yeah
anguish gentlemen ghost
calendar man and the condiment King are
you making some of those up nope they're
all real you guys ready to save Gotham
see
[Music]
I am so sorry soon as I get back to the
Batcave I will make sure that Alfred
puts seatbelts on there but for the time
being I'm just gonna put my arm right
here
hey I'm rubbing my butt all over your
stuff I'm gonna have to rename this the
bun mobile
[Music]
you